but you know the thing about idol is um
it's just a fun gig i mean when you um
when you are part of
of being the first people to see a star
being born
i mean when you look at like i mean i
was riding down the road
listening to the radio and i'm listening
to gabby barrett's
second single and obviously we know that
you know um her first you know her first
single
was just massive and i'm like
god i never will forget her walking in
the room
and i knew that she was just
a world-class singer and um
and obviously working with lionel and
katie and ryan
it's no drama you know i'm like i'm not
trying to be a bigger star than katy
perry and
lord we we know we'll never be a bigger
star than lionel richie so
everybody has their fun little role and
we just focus on the kids we don't we're
not
in it for yeah you know we're not in it
to go
you know i'm i don't know the coolest
part to be surrounded by people i
i love that too link when you're i've
i've worked with actually
legend john legend on a couple different
shows um like
you know a singing competition show and
and one thing i love that
we've kind of had in on the previous
show and now on the voice like
is we both just love music we're like
that too like it's
that we really feed off of each other a
lot too and then obviously blake and
gwen's on this season so it's like
if once you have people you know you and
katie and y'all already established
you've already done so many things
you're already excited
and you make it about these artists you
know
yourself that's i think that's when you
win um inevitably and that's that's
really cool
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going